you may remember that early on starting
really i would say in last spring but
then it got really hot
in the summer there were a bunch of
doctors and a bunch of people online who
were talking about hydrochloroquine
and hydrochloroquine is a medicine that
many doctors were saying
at least could help prevent covid plenty
of people were booted from twitter from
this
videos were taken down on youtube
channels were deleted
doctors had their reputations destroyed
mobs going after their
their jobs and families and all of those
things well now there is a new study
that says that hydrochloroquine is
probably quite effective
in dealing with cova let's throw to fox
news and now
over a year later we have that data that
dr stephen smith
promised in a new study smith and three
other medical experts prove what he and
his this show have been telling you for
more than a year
that hydroxychloroquine can save lives
smith's landmark study followed 255
covid patients who required
intubation during the first two months
of the pandemic
and it found that increased doses of
co-administered hydroxychloroquine and
azithromycin
were associated with a greater than 100
percent
increase in survival
that's a study using science
saying some stuff now i'm not telling
you it's 100
true but the point is that many doctors
and reputable people and and a small
amount of journalists
and i that was that was an accidental
air quote some of these people are
actual journalists
they've been saying that we should be
looking into this for a long time as a
matter of fact the video
that i'm about to show you of dr stella
emmanuel in dc
which went viral and then was taken down
uh you may remember this well
i at trump rallies last fall was out
there and i went out there with dennis
prager and i said dennis
we we didn't have masks on it i was okay
without having a mask and i said dennis
well aren't you afraid you're out here
without a mask and you know dennis is
in his early 70s he said no i'm on
hydrochloroquine i'll i'll be just fine
uh now let's take a look at this video
that you may remember from
dr stella emanuel and this is last
summer i'm a true testimony
so i came here to washington dc to tell
america
nobody needs to get sick this virus has
a cure it is called hydroxychloroquine
zinc and zitromax i know people want to
talk about mask hello
you don't need masks there is a cure i
know they don't want to open schools
no you don't need people to be locked
down there is prevention
and there is a cure i want to be very
clear about something that video was
was censored across the internet okay
that's number one number two
uh she's now saying well she's saying
then
that things that we now know are true
that the masks don't quite work
that's what fouchy's emails have said
right we know this and we know that
lockdowns don't work
which is why the numbers in florida and
texas that were largely open
in many cases were far better than
places that locked down
like california and new york so that
woman who was then
you know called she was literally called
a white supremacist and and the rest of
the nonsense and actually we were going
to have her on the show and i had to
have a big internal debate
whether we were going to do it because
we were already on you know we knew they
were looking at us already
and whether we would get our channel
deleted and everything else and i was
still setting up things
with locals to ensure that we'd be okay
on the on the back end of that
um i think you can see what's going on
here it's almost like
if you censor people then maybe the
censored people are actually saying
something kind of true and that's why
censorship
doesn't work um i mean a lot of people
owe that woman apology including jack
from twitter
and mark zuckerberg from facebook anyway
i'm not telling you it's 100
uh that the studies are 100 right right
like i'm not telling you that actually
maybe we'll try to get that doctor on
um we'll see we'll see if we can get him
be happy to talk about it so she may be
right
but the point is the media called her
crazy
and that's what the media seems to do
with anyone who dares say anything
close to the truth let's remember a few
months ago if you would
if you dared say that perhaps this was a
man-made virus
from a lab in wuhan that might have been
leaked either intentionally or not that
could have got you banned from twitter
now you're allowed to say it facebook
actually changed their policy altogether
if you had said that on facebook a few
months ago you were done
they were going to blow up your account
now they've actually made a statement
just in the last week because evidence
is leaking out
that you're actually okay if you were to
say these things so
man information war people
we are in a war on truth and uh
i guess i'm a general in the war on
truth i'm a general in the war
on truth and you guys are part of my
battalion and i promise you we're going
to win this thing